thousands of miles from Tokyo URI
hoodies family awaits Bernards arrival
even in remote corners of the tundra
news travels by radio and word of mouth
after a two-day drive
Bernard search is over ever since Lee
was discovery
he's wondered why she appeared on a
riverbank and where she really came from
chuckles any invasion that passes her
that's like months after his discovery
Yuri understands that whatever his
feelings about Luba the mammoth is
important for science and he's prepared
to help Bernard if he can we do with she
died
Ethel a structure a Festivus URIs wife
in their family are well aware that
Outsiders view baby mammoths arrival as
a blessing not a curse as an honor the
Selleck heart Administration named the
mammoth Luba after URIs wife are you
jubilant
nice to meet you so the baby mammoth was
named after you I mean you know nightie
there's a summer with us yes but I don't
like that here because finding mammoth
remains for us well how can I explain
it's a bad omen to find something like
this it may even be a curse that's why I
don't like this baby mama
after months of second-hand stories
about the baby mammoth Bernard is
grateful for the family's candor and
asks Yuri to share his story so after
you from Juba you left oh yeah Sally
and afterwards you returned to the
tundra I did no you idiot yes you know
it's really a strange story we really
put on what values term yet when I first
saw it I thought it was a baby elephant
it made me on these
but then I realized what it was and I
went to see my friend Carrie oh it was
Carioca called the administration and
they sent Andre gusoff from the museum
and silly hard to meet us so we took him
back to the tundra to pick up the baby
ma'am
but when we got there my wife Luba said
that the mammoth was gone it was a bad
sign the helicopter had to go but Andrea
stayed on with us I couldn't believe it
first the mammoth read to my family and
now this would everyone think that I
made the whole thing up but at least I
knew I could show him where it was where
I found the man I was glad that he
believed my story he made photos he took
GPS coordinates but he was pretty upset
about the ma'am of disappearing he
didn't know how he was going to explain
the situation to the authorities but he
had to report it and try to get an uber
back
the administration in your cellar got
everyone to help the mayor the police
even the army it took them only a few
hours to figure out where she was
they said the baby mammoth was no report
and asked Andre Kiril and me to meet
them there I had to make sure the museum
got the mammoth then they would be
responsible for
in no report the police were a big help
the man who stole it gave it to a
merchant the guy told him the baby
mammoth could sell for a lot of money
but when he found out that the police
were after him he carried it outside and
put it on display for the people he said
the police warned him that the mammoth
belonged to the administration they
didn't arrest him but they took away the
mammoth after all the trouble we went to
I was relieved that she was in good
hands but at that point we had to move
fast it was warming up and Andrei was
worried that Luba would start to decay
before he could get her back to the
museum